HIMSELF FROM POLIO IN THE 88**
LOCAL WARM SPRINGS.
>> Sandra: KEY NUMBERS.
REAL CLEAR POLITICS AVERAGE OF
POLLS HAS HIM TRAILING BIDEN IN
MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN BY 9
POINTS AND 5 POINTS
RESPECTIVELY AS YOU CAN SEE ON
THE SCREEN.
BIDEN AHEAD IN NEBRASKA’S
CONGRESSIONAL DISTRICT 2 BY
SEVEN POINTS.
IT IS CONSIDERED A TOSS-UP AND
IT IS WHERE THE PRESIDENT IS
HEADING TODAY.
LET’S BRING IN TIM MURTAUGH,
TRUMP 2020 COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR.
GREAT TO HAVE YOU HERE THIS
MORNING.
WE HAVE A LOT OF QUESTIONS BUT
FIRST WHAT IS THE MOOD OF THE
CAMPAIGN SEVEN DAYS OUT
ESPECIALLY AFTER I JUST READ
THROUGH THE POLLS THERE?
>> WELL, THE MOOD IS FANTASTIC.
WE’RE DEFINITELY UPBEAT AND
VERY CAUTIOUSLY OPTIMISTIC THE
PRESIDENT IS HEADED FOR
REELECTION.
WE KNOW WHAT’S GOING ON IN
THESE BATTLEGROUND STATES FROM
OUR OWN INTERNAL DATA AND KNOW
IN THE STATES THAT WILL MAKE
THE DIFFERENCE STATES LIKE
FLORIDA AND PENNSYLVANIA AND
MICHIGAN AND WISCONSIN, THE
PRESIDENT REMAINS STRONG AND IS
HEADED QUITE CLEARLY TO
REELECTION.
IF YOU LOOK AT THESE PUBLIC
POLLS AND HE HAVE TEN AVERAGE
IT IS A BUNCH OF AVERAGES OF
FLAWED POLLS.
THE NATIONAL NEWS MEDIA HAS
SPENT FOUR YEARS TRYING TO
DESTROY AND DEFEAT PRESIDENT
TRUMP AND SO I DON’T KNOW WHY
ANYONE WOULD PUT ANY STOCK AT
ALL IN POLLS PAID FOR BY THOSE
MEDIA ORGANIZATIONS.
OF COURSE THEY’LL PRODUCE
NUMBERS WHICH CONFIRM THEIR OWN
WORLDVIEW.
YOU TAKE THE AVERAGE.
IT IS AN AVERAGE OF ALL THOSE
BAD POLLS.
SO WE KNOW WHAT’S REAL.
>> Sandra: I GET YOU ARE
DISMISSING THE POLLS AS WE HAVE
OFTEN HEARD FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
THERE ARE REAL NUMBERS THAT WE
CAN LOOK AT INCLUDING SOME OF
THE POSITIVITY RATES IN THE
STATE THE PRESIDENT IS VISITING
TODAY WHERE CORONAVIRUS IS
STILL A VERY REAL CONCERN AND
JOE BIDEN IS STILL STRONGLY
POLLING ABOVE THE PRESIDENT
WHEN IT COMES TO WHO WOULD
HANDLE THE PANDEMIC BETTER IN
MICHIGAN, OHIO, PENNSYLVANIA
AND WISCONSIN.
TIM, WISCONSIN’S POSITIVITY
RATE SEVEN DAY MOVING AVERAGE
28%.
NEBRASKA 22%, IN WISCONSIN IT’S
UP 53% OVER THE LAST TWO WEEKS
POSITIVE CASES.
THE MORNING THE A.P. IS WRITING
WORST PLACE, TRUMP FACES VIRUS
-- WHY TALK ABOUT LOCK DOWNS
WHEN BATTLING THE VIRUS ITSELF
WHEN HE ADDRESSES VOTERS?
>> THE PRESIDENT IS BATTLING
THE VIRUS ITSELF.
THIS IS ANOTHER AREA WHERE
THERE IS A CLEAR CONTRAST
BETWEEN THE TWO, TRUMP AND
BIDEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WANTS PEOPLE TO
BE SAFE AND TAKE PRECAUTIONS
BUT KNOWS WE CANNOT LET THE
VIRUS LOCK US DOWN AGAIN.
HE HAS BEEN IN A NINE-MONTH
BATTLE AGAINST THE VIRUS AND
HAS POSTED A WHOLE BUNCH OF
VICTORIES AND A LOT OF GOOD
NEWS.
THE PRODUCTION OF PPE, MASKS,
NOW THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE
THERAPEUTICS, REMDESIVIR BEING
APPROVED BY THE FDA.
WE’RE THIS CLOSE FROM GETTING A
VACCINE APPROVED OR
DISTRIBUTION AND FIRST GOING TO
THE MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
JOE BIDEN THE CANDIDATE OF
LOCKDOWNS.
HOW WE’RE FACING A DARK WINTER.
THAT IS NOT AN OPTIMISTIC
MESSAGE.
IF YOU TALK ABOUT LOCKING
PEOPLE DOWN AGAIN, FOR HOW LONG?
SIX MONTHS, A YEAR, 18 MONTHS?
REMEMBER, IN CHINA THEY WELDED
PEOPLE INTO THEIR HOMES.
DOES HE RECOMMEND A SIMILAR
STYLE APPROACH?
I DON’T KNOW.
IF YOU HEAD THE COUNTRY TOWARDS
ANOTHER LOCK DOWN.
LOCK THE ECONOMY DOWN IT WOULD
BE DEVASTATING TO PEOPLE.
MAYBE IF YOU ARE ON A SALARY OR
IF YOU CAN WORK FROM HOME YOU
CAN GET BY WITH THAT.
BUT YOU CANNOT SURVIVE IF YOU
ARE IN THE SERVICE INDUSTRIES,
IF YOU WORK WITH YOUR HANDS.
YOU CAN’T STAY LOCKED UP IN
YOUR HOUSE FOR ANOTHER
PROLONGED PERIOD.
JOE BIDEN IS OFFERING EXACTLY
THAT.
THAT’S THE CONTRAST.
>> Sandra: THAT MESSAGE
RESONATES WITH SOME VOTERS WHO
ARE RESTRICTED BY THE SHUTDOWNS.
JOE BIDEN SEES A SERIOUS
OPPORTUNITY HERE.
HERE WAS JOE BIDEN YESTERDAY
REALLY TAKING ON THE PRESIDENT
AND HIS COVID RESPONSE.
LISTEN.
>> SATURDAY DONALD TRUMP SAID
THE COVID-19 COUNT WASN’T GOING
UP.
IT WAS LEVELING OUT.
HE SUGGESTED THAT DOCTORS WERE
INFLATING THE NUMBERS, CATCH
THIS, BECAUSE DOCTORS GET MORE
MONEY.
WHAT IN THE HELL IS THE MATTER
WITH THIS MAN?
>> Sandra: IS THIS MESSAGE
WORKING FOR JOE BIDEN?
>> , NO AND IT SHOULDN’T
BECAUSE THIS IS THE SAME JOE
BIDEN THAT WE KNOW WOULD NOT
HAVE RESTRICTED TRAVEL FROM
CHINA LIKE PRESIDENT TRUMP DID
BECAUSE HE CALLED IT XENOPHOBE
AND FEAR MONGERING.
WE KNOW WE’D BE IN A FAR WORSE
POSITION TODAY AS A COUNTRY IF
JOE BIDEN HAD BEEN PRESIDENT AT
THAT TIME.
JOE BIDEN, LOOK, THROUGHOUT ALL
OF THIS JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN
COMPLETELY UNBURDENED BY THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF LEADERSHIP.
EVERY MINUTE OF THIS CRISIS HE
HAS TAKEN THE CORONAVIRUS AND
TURNED IT INTO A POLITICAL
WEAPON.
EVEN TO THE POINT OF TRYING TO
SCARE PEOPLE AWAY FROM TAKING
THE LIFE-SAVING VACCINE WHEN IT
IS READY AND APPROVED AND ON
THE MARKET FOR PEOPLE TO GET.
WHICH BY THE WAY PEOPLE WILL BE
RECEIVING FOR FREE UNDER THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
HE SPENDS ALL OF HIS TIME
TRYING TO FRIGHTEN PEOPLE AWAY
FROM TAKING THE VACCINE.
THAT IS RECKLESS, IT IS TAKING
SOMETHING THAT IS SO IMPORTANT
TO SAVING LIVES, MAKING PEOPLE
AFRAID OFIST.
THAT IS ENDANGERING PEOPLE’S
LIVES SIMPLY TO SCORE POLITICAL
POINTS.
IT IS RECKLESS AND
IRRESPONSIBLE.
>> Sandra: I WANT TO HEAD TO
IMMIGRATION.
HERE WAS THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY TALKING ABOUT THE
BORDER.
>> President Trump: WE’RE GOING
TO DEFEND OUR BORDERS.
THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
WE JUST HIT 400 MILES.
THAT’S A LOT.
THIS IS A WALL THAT IS EXACTLY
WHAT BORDER PATROL AND ALL OF
THE LAW ENFORCEMENT PEOPLE
WANTED.
>> Sandra: WHERE IS THE
MESSAGING WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION, THE BORDER, THE
WALL.
IT DOMINATED THE 2016 TRUMP
CAMPAIGN, TIM.
HERE IS A HEADLINE IN THE "WALL
STREET JOURNAL." FRONT PAGE
THIS MORNING.
TRUMP CAMPAIGN TONES DOWN
IMMIGRATION MESSAGES THAT
DOMINATED 2016 ELECTION.
IT SAID THE ISSUE BARELY MAKES
THE TOP 10 LIST OF TOPICS
HIGHLIGHTED IN POLITICAL TV ADS.
IT WAS A "WALL STREET JOURNAL"
REVIEW THAT FOUND IT WAS THE
FOURTH MOST MENTIONED ISSUE IN
HIS 2016 CAMPAIGN BUT HAS
BARELY CRACKED THE TOP 10 THIS
CYCLE AROUND.
WAS THAT A CONCERTED EFFORT TO
TRANSITION AWAY FROM THAT TOPIC
THAT DID SO WELL FOR THE
PRESIDENT IN 2016, TIM?
>> NO, AND AS A MATTER OF FACT
THE SOUND BITE FROM THE
PRESIDENT YOU JUST PLAYED
PROVES THAT’S NOT THE CASE.
THE PRESIDENT STILL TALKS ABOUT
THIS ISSUE AT EVERY SINGLE
RALLY JUST ABOUT.
IT SETS UP A VERY CLEAR
CONTRAST YET AGAIN.
NO ONE CAN MISTAKE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE
CANDIDATE WHO WILL ENFORCE OUR
BORDERS, ENFORCE OUR
IMMIGRATION LAWS, PROTECT
AMERICAN WORKERS AND KEEP OUR
COMMUNITIES SAFE BY OPPOSING
SANCTUARY CITIES AS WELL.
JOE BIDEN ON THE OTHER HAND
PROMISES AN OPEN BORDERS POLICY.
HE SAID FOR THE FIRST 100 DAYS
IF HE IS ELECTED HE WON’T
DEPORT ANYBODY.
ANYBODY.
AFTER 100 DAYS HE WOULD DEPORT
ONLY THOSE ILLEGAL ALIENS WHO
HAD COMMITTED FELONIES.
HE WOULD GRANT AMNESTY TO 11
MILLION ILLEGAL ALIENS.
GIVE THEM ALL TAXPAYER FUNDED
HEALTHCARE AND PROVIDE THEM
WORK PERMITS SO THEY CAN
COMPETE WITH AMERICANS FOR JOBS
THAT THEY NEED COMING OUT OF
THE CORONAVIRUS CRISIS.
ON TOP OF THAT JOE BIDEN WILL
SUPPORT SANCTUARY CITIES, A
SLAP IN THE FACE OF THOSE
COMMUNITIES WHO WANT SAFE
STREETS.
IT’S A BIG ISSUE AND NO WONDER
SOME PARTS OF THE MEDIA IS
SAYING IT’S TAKEN AWAY ARE AS
AN ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT IS TALKING ABOUT
THAT ALL THE TIME.
>> Sandra: WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ECONOMY AXIOS RAN A HEADLINE
THIS WEEK THAT PRESIDENT TRUMP
DOES NOT HAVE A PLAN ON THE
ECONOMY.
HE TALKS ABOUT A BIG, BEAUTIFUL
TAX CUT BUT HAVEN’T GOTTEN REAL
DETAILS FROM THE CAMPAIGN.
WILL WE HEAR MORE IN THE COMING
DAYS?
WILL HE GET MORE SPECIFIC ABOUT
THOSE TAX CUTS AND WHAT HIS
PLAN IS TO DO TO GET US OUT OF
THIS RUT THAT WE’RE IN DUE TO
THE PANDEMIC?
>> VOTERS KNOW THAT THE
PRESIDENT BUILT THE WORLD’S
BEST CONE ME ONCE AND IS
ALREADY DONE IT A SECOND TIME.
HIS APPROACH HAS ALWAYS BEEN TO
KEEP TAXES LOW, ALLOW PEOPLE TO
MAKE MORE DECISIONS FOR
THEMSELVES HOW TO SPEND THEIR
OWN MONEY THEY’VE EARNED.
KEEP REGULATIONS GO.
GET GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE WAY
OF ENTREPRENEURS, GET
GOVERNMENT OUT OF THE WAY OF
FARMERS SO FARMERS CAN THRIVE.
WHAT DO YOU HAVE ON THE OTHER
SIDE?
JOE BIDEN THE PRESIDENT SAID AT
THE TOP OF THIS SEGMENT.
JOE BIDEN’S MAIN PLAN.
LOOK, I WILL LET --S YOU KNOW
THE CAMPAIGN DOESN’T WRITE
LEGISLATION.
THE PRESIDENT’S GOAL IS TO KEEP
TAXES LOW.
HE HAS TALKED ABOUT FURTHER
CUTTING TAXES FOR THE MIDDLE
CLASS.
OFTEN TALKED ABOUT ALLOWING
PEOPLE TO KEEP MORE OF WHAT
THEY EARN.
MAKING IT CHEAPER FOR
BUSINESSES TO HIRE PEOPLE AND
LOOK AT WHAT JOE BIDEN IS
OFFERING, RAISING THE CORPORATE
TAX RATE.
THAT WILL MAKE IT MORE
EXPENSIVE TO DO BUSINESS IN THE
UNITED STATES THAN IT IS IN
CHINA.
ANOTHER CASE OF JOE BIDEN
LOOKING OUT FOR CHINA AHEAD OF
AMERICAN WORKERS, PLUS RAISING
TAXES BY $4 TRILLION.
IF YOUR QUESTION IS WHO IS
BETTER ON THE ECONOMY, WE
WELCOME AND WE’RE DYING FOR
THAT ARGUMENT.
BECAUSE IT IS QUITE CLEARLY
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND IT IS NOT
EVEN CLOSE.
EVEN THE BAD PUBLIC POLLS SHOW
THAT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS THE LEADER
ON THE ECONOMY.
HE BUILT THE WORLD’S BEST
ECONOMY ONCE AND DOING IT A
SECOND TIME.
JOE BIDEN IS A DISASTER.
VOTING FOR NAFTA, CARING MORE